- So what's your most memorable video
that you've ever been apart of?
- My most, well the one I get
the most when I see people
is I have a friend and we
were just jokin' around
and he tells me, he's like,
"You'll never find love.
"You'll never find someone to
marry you," like as a joke.
So then the next day I flew to Boston
without him knowing and
I proposed to his mother,
(audience laughing)
and then yeah.
- That's the ultimate revenge!
- It was great,
it was great, so I proposed to his mom
and then I flew her to
Vegas to get married.
(audience laughing)
- Like for real
you got married?
- 100% real.
I was nervous because
at first you have to go
to this court house to get the papers,
and I was like maybe I shouldn't do this
'cause this is pretty serious,
but then I also didn't wanna fake it.
So getting married is so easy,
so easy!
(audience laughing)
It took like--
- Staying married
is a little more difficult.
- Bingo!
(all laughing)
That's what I found out, too.
So we got married and
then we flew to Hawaii
for our honeymoon, and we
did this in three, four days
without him knowing where I was,
so we went to the honeymoon,
she stayed down on the ground
- You married his mom?
- And I was sky diving.
- First of all she's funny.
- She's great.
- I love his mom.
- She's so great.
At first she was confused,
but then I was like, "I
wanna be Jason's stepdad."
(Kelly laughing)
And she was like all for it, yeah.
(audience clapping)
- That's amazing!
- That is hilarious!
- Thanks!
And then four days later we
flew back and we went back
into the car we were before
and I showed him the documents,
all the court house documents,
that I'm officially his new stepdad
and that was one of my favorite moments.
- Oh my--
- He loved it too,
he was glad his mom was in town
'cause I brought her from Hawaii to L.A.
So everyone won at the end.
- Oh my gosh, that's amazing.
Can we roll part of that?
Can we see part of that
'cause I wanna see it.
- Me too!
- Oh, there's a clip.
- Will you marry me?
- Are you out your mind?
- I wanna be Jason's stepdad.
- Oh that would be hysterical.
- That's why I'm here!
(everyone laughing)
- Power invested in me
by the state of Nevada,
I now pronounce you husband and wife.
You may kiss the bride.
- I love you.
- Okay, let's go.
- [David] Very beautiful.
(audience cheering)
- That was amazing.
- Yeah.
- So,
- That was fun.
- That's the best prank ever.
- Yeah, that's a lot of fun to do.
- Wow, it's good
he took it well.
- I would recommend everybody
marries their best friends mom.
Yeah, he took it very
well, that's the best part
is he was such a good sport about it.
- That's so awesome.